bonjour Patrick caner merci de nous
rejoindre ici en direct sur l'aine de
public sa on voit cette proposition
d'une résolution voulue par Bruno
rotillo est-ce que les socialistes
pourrai joindre leur signature à cette
résolution brun rotillot en sa qualité
de président du premier groupe a pris
déjà ce type d'initiative sur l'Ukraine
sur aussi le Hard donc le
haabak près de l'Arménie voilà donc on n
est pas du tout opposé il faut bien sûr
voir son mais ce qui est très important
c'est de montrer que sur des sujets qui
peuvent être très consensuels en droit
international et bien oui les
socialistes sont prêts à signer en
fonction bien sûr de son contenu est-ce
que dans cette résolution il pourrait
être question de de ces fameux crimes
contre l'humanité que Géral lcher
souhaite qualifier comme tel il appelle
l'exécutif à à utiliser ces mots il
appelle l'exécutif à dire à nos
partenaires européens de reprendre cette
expression vous êtes d'accord avec C oui
il faut nommer les choses savez la
notion de crime contre l'humanité relève
du droit international c'est extrêmement
précis ce que nous avons euh vécu
assister depuis le 7 octobre montre que
euh voilà ce n'est pas uneé une armée
régulière qui a commis ces ces actes
monstrueux insoutenables c'est bien une
bande de terroristes qui voulait
permettez-moi l'expression tu es du Juif
c'était bien cela dont il était question
malheureusement pendant ce ce weekend
face à à à ce constat sans appel que
vous évoquez que dire de ce malaise à
gauche autour du fait de nommer le Hamas
comme un un un groupe terroriste vous
avez parler d'indignité lors de cette
séance vous visez très clairement les
les insoumis ils ont commis une
indignité en refusant C je je ne vise
pas les insimés en tant que parti je
vise certains leaders et pas tous
d'ailleurs monsieur Ruffin a eu une
position différente courageuse et un
autre député nous le savons de Paris je
considère que effectivement à force de
tourner autour du pot peut-être pour des
raisons électorales mais ça c'est à
l'ffi de de l'évoquer et bien ils sont
en train de se couper de ce que devrait
être la gauche de responsabilité vous
connaissez mes critiques sur la nuupè
sur LFI et bien j'ai le sentiment
malheureusement que j'avais raison et
depuis de nombreux mois donc que LFI
fassent son introspection pour faire
bouger les lignes justement on voit le
chef de votre parti le premier
secrétaire Olivier fort qui hésite à
quitter officiellement laanupe on a vu
dans le monde que ça aurait pu être dès
hier que ça a été annoncé on voit que ça
il y a une hésitation faut-il que votre
chef de fil le dise clairement le PS
n'appartient plus à la nuupe jusqu'à
nouvel ordre vous savez Olivier fort est
à la tête d'un parti démocratique qui
prend ses décisions de manière
collective et vous un bureau national
hier il aurait pu le proposer d il a un
bureau national hier mais nous avons un
conseil
national samedi donc c'estàd le
Parlement du PS et une résolution en ce
sens sera portée discutée nous verrons
bien si elle obtient la majorité et donc
vous vous soutiendrez samedi le fait de
sortir de la nuup ah moi je considère
que il y aura eu un avant et un après c
octobre
au de lae française mais malheureusement
nos affaires politiciennes sont
tellement peu de chos par rapport au
malheur que vit Isra aujourd'hui bien s
merci patri cette
réaction